[Musique]
françois mitterrand se dégage de la
foule de rose à la main il pénètre seul
à l'intérieur du panthéon
[Musique]
orchestre de paris joue maintenant
l'hymne à la joie le président de la
république va se recueillir devant le
tombeau de jean jaurès et du résistant
jean nina
françois mitterrand au panthéon le jour
de sa prise de fonction vous étiez rue
soufflot là aussi curiosité oui
absolument absolument mais vous savez
moi j'étais dans une famille gaulliste
une famille gaulliste de toujours et
vous savez que les gaullistes se sont
beaucoup déchiré en 81 ils ce sont des
celle entre ceux qui sont restés fidèles
à la droite à valéry giscard d'estaing
et ceux qui ont préféré voter françois
mitterrand et donc à table en famille
avec mes oncles mes tantes mes cousins
c'était des discussions homérique sur
giscaro mitterrand et donc moi je
regardais ça je regardais ça de
l'extérieur je me suis dit
qui sait ce mitterrand et j'avais le
sentiment que cette élection
présidentielle c'était un moment un
moment d'histoire et donc avec une amie
j'ai dit bah on va aller voir le moment
d'histoire et donc on avait on avait 13
ans et on est et on est venu regarder ce
spectacle au panthéon et moi j'ai aimé
le décorum j'ai aimé le décorum de 7,2
de ceux de cette marche vers le panthéon
mais ensuite j'ai regardé un peu plus
tard les actions de ce président
mitterrand et là j'ai pas du tout adhéré
j'ai absolument adhérer à rien j'ai
adhéré nier aux nationalisations nir à
sa politique économique ni à ce qu'il a
fait de la france donc je n'ai jamais
voté pour françois mitterrand
[Musique]